foreign
[Music]
for the holidays but it was worth it
why was he worth it because I get to see
my family
I'll see family on holidays I don't care
what it costs oh wait way higher than
normal I think ours were like over 600 a
piece they were very high
oh they've gotten very high I travel a
lot and they've probably doubled in some
instances now I'm thinking like maybe
it's cheaper to drive to see them but
then again gas is up high so it's like
all about finding that that balance and
trying to find ways to make extra cash
it actually wasn't as bad as I thought
it was gonna be like last year I feel
like it was way more expensive than it
was this year the airfare itself was was
cheap we're flying out again on
Christmas Day and I think it was super
affordable for the whole family so
it's pretty bad it's pretty bad it's
pretty bad because um like right now I
remember maybe a couple of years ago I
could go from I'm originally from
Florida so I could fly from here to
Florida from like
big box and now it's not like that
around the holidays for sure it
definitely increases in price but
initially when I first moved here what
would have cost me sixty dollars for a
round trip not cost about 150 on a
regular day and if you wait until the
holidays it edges more towards four to
five hundred for that same exact trip so
not only just inflation in general but
also the holidays makes a big impact on
traveling well we bought our tickets
about a month and a half ago so they
were reasonable enough
looks like the horse is over on
everything
uh mine was pretty expensive just
because I'm flying across the country
but I think all things considered I got
it pretty early so it was cheaper than
you know if I bought it last minute and
we did have to get help usually we
wouldn't want to get help to like travel
to go see family but they're always
willing to help out because of the
prices not just for the holidays I would
say the last three to six months but it
was
I feel like you can get lucky with
airfare whereas gas prices you kind of
get you know you get what you get you
have to try to budget and you have to
try to find them
right luckily before they have a couple
choices PBI and FLL
and then here there's three choices
depending where our clients are so
you can make it work I think it's
definitely cheaper than before cover but
it's still pretty pricey maybe you have
to plan sooner or you know like my my
mother always builds a whole chart for
all the deals and tries to watch it a
bit monitor it
um but you know often it's this chance
of getting lucky I'm sorry I would just
advise people to plan ahead and the
airline is very congenial when you get
to be my age
you do whatever you can to be with
family if I'm paying like a ridiculous
amount of money and it's like a bunch of
connecting flights I'm not gonna it's
like not worth it it really just depends
on the timing of it and you really have
to watch and be pay attention to what is
going to be the best bet for traveling
you've got to see family it's a mess no
matter what the inflation rate is
[Music]